the host of the original nickelodeon
show blues clues is stunning grown-up
fans of the late 90s kid show steve
burns left viewers heartbroken when he
left the show back in 2002 he told them
he was off to college leaving room for
his little brother to step in now in a
viral video byrne speaks directly to his
fans listen
i mean
we started out with clues
and now it's what
student loans and um jobs and families
and some of it
has been kind of hard
you know
i know you know
and i wanted to tell you that i i really
couldn't have done all of that without
your help i guess i just wanted to say
that after all these years
i never forgot you
ever
and i'm super glad we're still friends
thanks for listening you guys i love
this broke the internet this broke the
internet my producer kathleen wash said
she was crying as she was cutting the
videos and the sound bites for this
because she was of the era who watched
this show i mean i don't know if your
kids watch it now
but when he left it blew little kid's
mind so you remember that show very very
cool of course nickelodeon is part of
icon cbs we should always but that's not
why we're doing that that's not why
we're doing it it's because it literally
broke the internet people were really
psyched about this good to see steve